for the first time in 13 years Dutch
fashion designers Victor and wife will
be presenting a new odd couture
collection the scene is an art center in
Paris's central limit a district models
are still being styled as guests start
to arrive Victor and wife are known for
surprises
I want it to stay a little very excited
I have no idea what they're going to do
but I have a hunch it'll be along
conceptional lines to Jolo good day I'm
pickle cept influential British fashion
critic Suzy Menkes wouldn't miss this
one the opening is more drama than
fashion the two designers sit on the
stage in a lotus position for several
minutes before the audience gets
Restless the show is underway but it's
still more of a performance with the
designers in the middle of it the
inspiration was as you have seen a
japanese zen garden because we find it
the most beautiful symbol of mindfulness
and serenity
we wanted to communicate that as a state
of mind the state of mind were in it
being behind the scenes but then this
idea needs us in a way nobody else can
really do it the collection consists of
20 creations in black silk that seemed
almost like moving mutating sculptures
all the girls had a different posture
and be created to close photos Oscars
when they stand and walk up
the most conspicuous element is the
oversized metal zipper these creations
certainly are creative Secretary of an
anniversary and we wanted to celebrate
by creating something new
return to catira was perfect because the
tier is the perfect place to express
something very creative
we also wanted to separate the
conceptual artistic very creative part
of our work from the wearable part of
our work so that's we want to separate
ready-to-wear equal to your big toe and
Roth embarked on their own coach your
careers 20 years ago but they had
concentrated on ready to wear for women
and men even a collection for H&M
they're ready to wear or pet aparte
designs often came across like high
fashion creations the term audigier can
only be applied to legally defined
standards but still leaves room for
clothes like vest a cheese and yours
they have to be hand-sewn and custom
fitted one dress might run fifteen
thousand or more euros there are only a
few hundred buyers for them in the world
but what keturah has its own appeal for
designers opened on the Delta to
inspires you to dream but for most
designers it remains a dream it's
reserved for just a few so it's quite
elitists but it's good for your image
and a label can sell bags or perfumes
much better with an image like that
people feel just a bit closer to those
dreams with these accessories and it's
easier for them to afford a bottle of
perfume on the Saturday on the phone
Victor and wife's audience has just seen
one of the more unusual shows of the
Paris odd couture season to Tyler egg
knitting insignia the production was
quite distinctive it was almost hard to
follow I almost missed the show because
my mind was somewhere else I had to
eventually settle back and concentrate
but it was wonderful really really great
the big general facing those
masterfully uses lots of
and I really expected that something
will come closer to the end of the show
I don't know the beautiful red dress or
yellow dress but anyway this was a very
untraditional show and interesting
runway experience the two designers
toasted to their 20 years in the
business and they're returned to Oak
keturah they don't even have to worry
about how successful their new
collection will be parts of it have
already been sold to an art collector
you
you